hello everyone and welcome to this video
tutorial on how to quickly check games
that you're watching and even a game
that you may have just played with our
new chess comm slash analysis tool with
live stockfish engine updates first
we're gonna go into the play and enter
our live server you'll notice in this
case it automatically switches to my
favorite left side now let's go ahead
and follow a top game in progress by
clicking on the observe icon here and
check out a game currently in progress
is a game that will be ending very
shortly but fun thing for us in this
video we don't actually have to wait for
this game to end this button you see
right here is the share button clicking
it will not only allow you instant
sharing possibilities on a host of
social networks but the download looking
icon is not just for actually
downloading the PGN but you can actually
grab any live position this random list
of numbers is known as a fenced ring for
those who don't know it a fenced ring
every legal chess position has a fenced
ring or I can grab the entire PGN click
copy and now I'm gonna head on over to
chess comm / analysis or I'm gonna find
it here on the learn tab click analysis
and suddenly if I didn't believe that
those guys were playing the best moves I
can load the PGN myself and there we go
stock fish is calculating he's actually
considering as the evaluation changes
and it allows me if I would like to to
go through their game and see what stock
fish thought through about through the
whole process of course I'm doing this
as an observer right now and so I
continue to say going through their game
but there's no reason why you can't do
it with your own game to check on how
you played learn and even save analysis
as the evaluation changes and we get
closer to the live position seems like
black was really much better and then
maybe it's it's it's closer to equal now
of course we don't even know how the
game ended it's not really useful for
this video the last thing that is useful
for this video is that in the analysis
tool you not only have a list of stock
fishes top three options you could hold
your mouse over any one of those moves
to see sort of a preview board of what
might happen in that line you can see
the evaluation changing of course if I
hold my mouse over it allows me
close it out if I'm not interested in
what stockfish thinks or get a little
more information about what I'm looking
at now one of the things I really like
is not just the stock fish running and
the preview of the board or my instant
ability to copy all awesome things I've
showed so far but that I can actually
right click on any of these moves and I
have analysis features I can add an
evaluation I can actually add a comment
before or after good job good job chess
comm X clam and when I'm done with all
of this I'm not gonna lose any of the
information I have I can actually click
download again and once again the
variations come up not only with the
game I paste it but do you recognize
that good job chess comm there that's
right
anything you do in our analysis editor
editor allows you instant saving
capabilities you can save a PGN to a
regular text document or if you have
tools such as chess bass or other types
of free open-source software programs
like arena or chess X save all your PG
ends analyze them with a top engine and
use our analysis features that are fun
and easy as well as really functionally
connected to all the games you play on
chefs comm from observing live chess
games as I just did your daily chess
games your own live chess games anything
thanks for watching this video on how to
use chess calm slash analysis and our
analysis board editor and I will see you
on chess calm